look who we have here a member of the
family alumnus of the old pro football
talk show on nbcsn our good friend
former buccaneers quarterback who won
the first playoff game in franchise
history he's sean king what's up sean
i'm good how are you doing
doing great buddy great to see you're
also the guy that threw the pass
that bert emanuel caught that touched
the ground that caused the rule change
that screwed up the nfl for 20 years
yeah i'm still looking for that replay
rep if you find him let me know
what do you remember most from that game
you guys came so close to beating that
great rams team 11 to
6 or 11 to 5 was a final score what what
stands out to you the most from that all
these years later
well now when you see all the technology
and the communication that exists
between
a controversial play or what's deemed to
be a controversial play and how it's
communicated it was so different back
then like we actually called timeout
after the catch and we had no idea that
the play was even being reviewed
i remember just like yesterday i had
actually called the next play in the
huddle and we were breaking the huddle
and the referee was standing over the
ball and he said
that was the first time that we kind of
it was brought to our attention that
something may be
you know
not right so you know just the fact that
we didn't even know
you know was one of the fascinating
aspects of aspects of that that not a
lot of people would know
sean i was there when you were drafted
in 1999 and that was a great team you
guys played on one of the best defenses
two hall of famers now
obviously the 2002 team won the super
bowl what was the best team in tampa bay
ever you think
oh
well defensively i think it was a 99
team and if you look at the allocation
of allocation of resources all the money
was on that side of the ball
and uh john gruden did a great job when
he came in but also i think
organizationally for the first time they
invested on offense we added keanu
mccardell we had a joe juror vicious we
had it ricky dudley michael pittman
thomas jones
for the first time since i had been
there we actually put a lot of our
resources from a salary cap standpoint
on offense so i think that's what got us
over the hunt because now we had an
offense that can actually
you know
pick up for our defense regularly when
they weren't playing at the highest
level
do you think it's possible these days
shine to win
on defense to win with the great defense
and maybe not a top franchise
quarterback i mean you look at these two
quarterbacks in the game they're two of
the best quarterbacks and perhaps headed
toward nfl history for patrick mahomes
and obviously for brady he's already
there but can you
win with defense
the old adage
i think you can i think what's happened
is
the finish line has been adjusted to
what great defense is you know in 1989
and o2 great defense was you held an
opponent under 20 points like you hit
the quarterback you were physical with
the wide receivers after the catch
like you just went out and had a
dominant physical defense to me now in
2020 21 uh you can win with defense but
it's got to be based on turnovers you've
got to have a group that can take away
the football from the other team's
offense and give your guys extra
possessions because the rule changes
have you know made it so that you can't
play that same physical brand of defense
hey sean these two teams are going to be
playing on sunday known for offense
their defenses get overlooked they're
both pretty good the chiefs have been
good all year the buccaneers have gotten
a lot better in recent weeks which of
the two defenses would you rather face
if you were the quarterback
the chiefs absolutely you know i don't
think the chiefs are
near as
good as they were last year on defense
whereas i think tampa can literally line
up with four down lyman and rush
shackberry jpp and get consistent
pressure
we got two of the best linebackers in
national football league in devon white
and lavonte david and then his name's
not mentioned a lot but kevin ross has
done a tremendous job this secondary
when you're talking about a young group
of players even though they're talented
they've been very inconsistent
throughout the regular season they've
been outstanding the last two weeks
enforcing turnovers
getting past this defense on third down
like covering elite wide receivers and
one-on-one situations not getting bad
penalties in big situations so i think
tampa was a lot more talented
defensively and i think they're playing
at a higher level currently
you know it's been 18 years since the
last time the buccaneers were in the
super bowl and it's a different kind of
a world now obviously but how does the
excitement level in tampa this time
compared to how it was the last time
around in 2002
well this is title town and everyone i
know you have a nationals a lot of
people that watch and and you know
listen we are telling you guys this is
title town usa
tampa bay rays
series even though we didn't win it
we're in the world series
our hockey team attempted realities win
their championship and now our nfl
professional football team attended my
communities are in the super bowl with a
chance to bring the lombardi trophy back
here for the second time so it's been a
pretty neat you know six to eight months
for this city and this is a great way to
you know put a blue on top
you've got a couple your teammates in
the hall of fame john lynch and rondae
barber finalists this year how cool will
it be especially for john he seems the
closest to getting in how cool would it
be to see him get in this year and just
kind of icing on top of the cake for uh
for the bucks
that would be great because not only are
john lynch and randy barber great
players are great people and they've
gone on and done tremendous things since
they retired from national football
league and
i think that should count for something
you know so i'd love to see john you
know get in i'd love to see one day get
in i think the organization deserves it
hands off to tony dungeon because that
would be all four
tambay buccaneers you know that are
still living that are in the hall of
fame were drafted you know if i'm not
mistaken by tony
though i might be wrong on that with
brooks and sat but i know he was a big
part of raising and developing them into
the players that they became so
he deserves a lot of credit for putting
that team together and i'd love to see
us you know get those last two guys in
i know you i hear your coaching now sean
do you enjoy the experience of coaching
i do the intrinsic value attached to it
is tremendous i mean
you're convincing a family to send you
their child and you're telling them that
you're going to nurture and take care of
him and help him grow from a boy to a
man and that's on and off the field so
when you see the byproduct of that on
the back end i mean it's very rewarding
sean you overlapped for a year in tampa
bay with chris sims now i've spent
almost four years with him
uh i you know one one year would be
enough frankly what's the give me the
chris sims memory
that stands out best story about chris
sims
he's white chocolate he's the palest
black dude i know
you know you look at him and you think
one thing and i mean he's the most
down-to-earth cool guy i've ever seen
you know he fit in with everybody you
know but i'll never forget uh
john was miked up i think we just moved
training camp over to disney
you know chris had one of those plays
last the wild bunch right up counter
motion 72 crisscross white swing x out
here we get mike saying we want to go 98
bunch crunch if you think you're getting
any kind of weak pressure go 200 jet
smoke and you know chris kind of fell
off a blast
and
it just it was it was so unique in that
he was trying to figure out how to
actually call plays and i think it took
him a whole first year to be the call
you know full play but i mean to watch
him grow and you know he's a great dude
what he's done you know in the media and
uh i miss him hey chris we wish you died
in temple i wish it was normal times i
could be there live and spend time with
all you guys
now sean he claims that after scoring a
touchdown in the playoff game against
washington in 2005
that he actually threw the ball not into
the pirate ship but into the hole in one
of the cannons
i don't believe it you've been on that
field you see how far it is you see what
kind of target that is is it possible
for someone to throw the football into
the hole in one of the cannons
well i mean
what he forgot to tell you was he was
trying to hit the scoreboard
so i do believe the ball could have went
in the cannon but i don't think he was
aiming for the cannon
he was aiming at the scoreboard
what's the key for the bucks in this
game
sean
i think we have to uh
control time of possession if you look
back at the regular season game between
kansas city and tampa the chiefs had the
ball for 36 minutes champ only had it
for 23. you know what a lot of that had
to do with our inability to convert
third downs or being manageable third
down so
you look at the saints and packers game
early in those games we were very
aggressive on third now third and short
throwing the ball deep we didn't convert
i think it's very imperative that you
keep patching the holes in that offense
on the sideline you limit their ability
to do damage by not allowing them to get
on the field so tampa has to control the
time of possession
everybody's talking obviously about the
mahomes brady match-up brady in his 10th
super bowl mahomes trying to go
back-to-back for the first time since
brady did it and no 304 i believe
or 0-405 whatever it was but how do you
see this quarterback matchup shaken out
well i think if two guys are
unbelievably successful i think they're
completely different
in how they find ways to win games i
think brady might be one of the best
leaders in professional sports history
regardless of football basketball hockey
or baseball just what he's been able to
do with a lot of different supporting
casts and getting those guys to believe
in what the goal was for that season and
finding a way to get it accomplished
that's second to none and we're dealing
with my homes i mean he's a unicorn i
mean he's one of the only guys i've ever
seen in the history of this league that
can beat you with his mind his arm or
his legs and those guys don't come
around that often so i mean two guys to
get it done in different ways but hey
this is what we wanted you know the one
the two things that brady brought to
tampa was
maturity and notoriety
fell off the national landscape i mean
we were not relative
to anything going on national football
league from a positive standpoint so
when he got here it became a national
brand and uh to go on the road and win
three playoff games in a row i mean
that's huge
a lot of people were unsure about the
chiefs late in the year that last
quarter this season you know even though
they found a way to win some games it
didn't look
you know does the whole cowboy have one
more you know gun battle that he can win
against this up and coming stud
sean you know i'm doing a little
research here on the fly and i'm doing a
little bit of rough math you're just a
couple of months older than tom brady
how in the hell from your perspective is
this guy still going and playing at a
high level at age 43
well him and drew brees got into yoga
and uh stretching before a lot of us i
never forget uh i had a conversation
with drew in 2001
you know even then all the resources
that he was putting towards
you know maintaining his body in the off
season and you know he was doing uh
mental gymnastics with you know hired
help you know so they were just ahead of
the game as far as the comprehensive
you know athletic plan you know for you
know january to december for an athlete
and i think lebron james gets a lot of
credit justifiably sold for being the
guy that really invests in his body
before the game during the game after
the game but in football drew brees and
tom brady were way ahead of the curve as
far as all those things are concerned
well hey sean we appreciate some of your
time as always it's great to see you
you're looking good looks like a great
day down there in tampa enjoy the week
enjoy the super bowl and we uh look
forward to talking to you soon pal
thanks for having me good to see both
you guys enjoy sunday
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports